we're here with the tournament leader
jordan von forrest
tell us how does it feel
yeah pretty surreal i have to say i
didn't
expect this at all of course um but uh
yeah i don't know the like the games i'm
winning everything is really flowing
smoothly for me and i'm really getting
the kind of positions which i like so
take us through those positions
let's get
started with here we had a berlin yes
were you aware that this particular
berlin had been played before in this
tournament
well i thought alireza but with knight
c3 as well because i thought alireza
played like c3 against wesley
dominguez wesley so in round one he won
bishop f4 oh no he didn't see that
bishop did part of your prep yeah
actually prepared it for topalov but
i i was choosing a little bit of lions
especially because
here i have a lot of choice and it's
like black is completely fine but with
the two bishops in rapid it can get
tricky as the game showed and
there's a lot of ways but i thought b3
is very tricky because actually d6 here
is inaccurate like you have to play d5
but it looks
humanly looks kind of strange to weaken
all the dark squares
and i believe like after bishop b2 you
should still play d5 according to the
computer which is very hard for a human
and after that it i think it's really
much better for white i knew this queen
before idea as well wow that's amazing
very strong preparation and very
practical in some ways kg that you're
trying to get your opponents to make
natural moves that seem like mistakes
yeah it tries to i mean in rapid it can
work out very well in classical like
these lines they're easily refuted and
opponents will find all the moves but in
rapid it's very hard to like navigate
your way through such a little bit
complicated lines where the bone has
some initiative i would say take us a
little bit of some of the key mistakes
of course is unpleasant but it's not
lost where did you feel he was starting
to lose the threat uh yeah so i knew
like queen g5 here is very logical but
then there's queen before
um so after bishop e6 i figured queen
before also has to move otherwise he can
play queen of six right if he tries
queen f6 here i think there's queenie
one and i'm yeah so i mean then
immediately i really like my position
and around here i was expecting him to
play h6 actually which
apparently is the computer move and
after rook g3 king of eight and i didn't
really see how to break through but
um
ah yeah i actually saw bishop takes h7
like after i played c4 oh but anyway the
white position is really easy to play
here and i thought maybe you should try
d5 here but i wasn't
i wasn't like dissatisfied here and it's
just in time trouble also for him it's
very hard position to play and all the
white moves are just coming so naturally
you had a huge time advantage over him
and then he hits you with a tactic now
queen to the background knight takes h2
do you feel that you were letting it go
or did you feel in control yeah well
with alireza you have to be extremely
careful your ease
not only he's just so incredibly tricky
so knight xh2 i did miss indeed but i i
immediately realized okay i'm still up
two pawns you know and my king is not
checkmated oh but actually yeah it's not
so clear afterwards i see my computer
but i thought it should still be winning
um actually i'm only at one point but i
thought like this king is much more
insecure and with the c5 it looked
really strong still for me so it was not
no i think i was like slip but it wasn't
the best technique i would say still
good enough for a rapid game how do you
feel going into the blitz do you
consider yourself a blitz specialist no
no no i'm terrible at blitz so don't
tell my opponents but um
yeah no i i think clas i like rapid is
actually my best time control and blitz
is my worst but i enjoy playing blitz
the most so i'll just try to enjoy and
take whatever point i can but it's going
to be very tough for sure well you're
nursing a nice advantage you're going to
be going into the blitz as solo first
places we don't expect wesley to win his
game actually let's go there immediately
see how that's going well it seems like
a
drawn end game yeah if anyone white has
to be careful but i guess the king is
just in time to pick up those pawns on
the queen side absolutely so you're
going to be guaranteed first place going
into the blitz good job so far good luck
in the blitz thank you so much guys back
to the studio just a couple of games
left in the rapids here in zagreb thank
you alejandro thank you jordan you hear
this